Dylan Mulvaney who caught brought all of
this onto himself right by putting up
these crazy videos pretending to be a
girl I blame also the Bud Light
Executives who got him involved in all
of this but he put this video up he is
currently in Peru at Machu Picchu which
is one of the seven wonders of the world
that we discussed yesterday and he's
still he's still a victim in all of this
hi is this an okay time okay surprise
I'm in Peru and I'm at Machu Picchu
isn't this just so beautiful
um I'm here by myself and I used to do a
ton of solo traveling I'm telling you
it's the best if you could ever do a
solo trip somewhere it is such a good
way to get to know yourself better
um but I came here to feel something you
know what I mean and I definitely have
I've done Shaman ceremonies that were
like 10 years worth of therapy it was
wild
um I've seen a lot of llamas and the
people here are so kind I feel very safe
here it's a little sad that I had to
leave my country to feel safe but that
will get better eventually and I am
dying for some Trader Joe's rolled chili
lime chips but other than that I am so
content still haven't been kissed yet
but I'm holding out hope
and most of all you know this trip has
just has me feeling like I'm My Own best
friend again and that is the best
feeling in the world and I hope that you
feel that way about yourself too
and I love ya okay
bye
Machu Picchu wow gorgeous
all right first off as Brock just
pointed out we have no reason to believe
that Dylan Mulvaney is now sponsored by
Trader Joe's I don't want everybody to
now boycott Trader Joe's I have no
problem with Trader Joe's for many many
years I shopped at Trader Joe's that's
not my closest supermarket anymore but
he just happens to like those chili lime
chips at Trader Joe's let's not go crazy
people uh but this idea that he had to
flee the country but despite doing
Shaman work uh work with shamans right
and like all sort of self-actualization
stuff he's still out there taking the
things oh I had to flee the country this
this like out of control crazy ego thing
[Music]
thank you